[Music]
Chloe keeps posting the most adorable
photos of true how she doing is there a
night yeah really really really great
yeah
loving being a mom anyway we can get her
back in LA so you can have that
grandbaby with me back really soon
talk to me via a gushing grandma with me
right now how are all of your babies
doing right now what is life like for
you oh good well every day I mean I get
I'm so lucky because we all live very
close to each other so I get to see my
grandchildren very often like every day
so it's the best it's just the best you
see them grow up and you know change and
lose teeth and yesterday I took north to
school and they had crazy hair day so I
wore a blonde wig thinking I'd be the
cool grandma you know at school and
North was rolling her eyes probably
mortified that her grandmother wore a
blonde wig was so funny I mean a crazy
blonde way here we are at the American
woman premiere how does it feel to
support your friend tonight well I'm so
excited I've known her for decades and
so this feels really good to see all of
her dreams come true and I knew her mom
Cathy and so this is you know full
circle the show that is inspired by
Kyle's mom if your daughters were to
create a show about you what do you hope
it would be called I don't know maybe
Chris knows best
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]